hey what's up y'all we're celebrating
all things nyc
on the kelly clarkson show today so to
honor my favorite five boroughs
i'm going to guess some new york city
slang
flying rats oh i know this one
because my nanny can't stand birds those
are pigeons
yeah i love pigeons i love birds
so she hates birds so anytime we're
somewhere i always try and get them to
like fly up
because that's who i am bridge and
tunnel
so i'm taking it it's not it's not a
bridge or a tunnel
maybe it's a fun position i don't know
why i don't know virgin tunnel um bridge
and tunnel
um i'm gonna say i don't know that one
so those are the people that come into
new york city commuting
from new jersey they either come over a
bridge or under a tunnel to get into the
city so there are commuters outside of
new york city
for coming in from other places so they
call him like
oh she's a bridger or she's a or a
bridge and tunnel they always say bridge
and tunnel yeah
which is kind of more to say than just
commuter
i'm just just pointing it out all right
next up
is schmitz i think i've heard someone
saying schwitz
like um is it like are you sweaty or
perspiring
schmitz yeah yes
uh bodega a bodega like a little area
a little shop like a little like a
little cafe kind of thing a bodega okay
yeah free it's bodega you have to say
with your sexy voice
a johnny pump is that like a like when
you get a flat tire like a jack a johnny
pump i feel like this could also be some
kind of weird position
the fire hydrant what
the guy who invented the fire hydrant i
guess is oh
a johnny pump okay pie
once again uh pie
so oh pizza they call new yorkers call
pizza
pie i didn't know that scent up the
river
send them up the river because you don't
care about them
because you're like you sent them up the
river because you're like
go find someone up the river that gives
a
you know no send up the up the river
directionally like to tell him to get
somewhere
now sent up the river we sent up the
river well going up the river is
dumb you're fighting the current you
know you're fighting the
why would you do that sent up the river
it means that you're going to jail
because at the top of the hudson river
is a jail correctional facility
so when you say oh i got sent up the
river it means he went to jail
damn all right well that was harder than
i thought
um guess this just means i have to visit
nyc again soon when it's safe
um so tag your favorite new yorker below
and see how well they do
it'll most definitely be better than me
that's fine
but now i know the more you know
you